Theresa Odin doll author of charity
begins at home
generosity and self-interest among the
philanthropic elite why do we need a
book like this well several reasons one
I think in the last decade the two
conservative administrations have been
cutting back on the provision of basic
Human Services and saying that the
private sector is going to take over the
provision of these services through
philanthropy and charity and so on and
so I decided to interview some
multimillionaires and find out what it
is that they give their money to and in
fact I found out that they tend to
support the types of institutions that
benefit them in their class to a much
greater extent than programs that serve
the needy so I'm calling the government
to task on their assumption and
President Bush's rhetoric about a
thousand points of light and how this
will make up for government lack where
do you come from San Diego California
how did you get to this point where have
you been since bright I worked I don't
know if you want to go all the way back
to my birth but I worked at two
different foundations and through
working at the First Foundation the
business and professional Women's
Foundation which is here in Washington
DC I was drawn into the kind of arena of
nonprofit organizations and foundations
in particular and I attended
professional conferences where I met
trustees of foundations and wealthy
people and so on so that sort of brought
me into research in this field and then
I was recruited to Yale after I got my
PhD I was recruited to Yale University
to head up a project in which we studied
the health of foundations in general
across the country and out of that
project the idea for this book emerged
although it's a very separate project
where'd you go to school the University
of Colorado at Boulder get all your
schooling from there no I went to San
Diego State College and then the
University of Colorado and I'm an
anthropologist and I noticed in your
past that you have been supported
time to time by foundations how often
and what foundations the foundations
that supported the project at Yale were
the Charles Stewart Mott Foundation the
andrew mellon foundation and the kellogg
foundations and this was a very large
study I was the project manager but we
had a team of seven other researchers on
it prior to that I did a study of
foundation career patterns and the
foundations that supported that project
were the Russell Sage Foundation and the
John Hay Whitney Foundation so I've
gotten a lot of support from foundations
at the point though that my analysis
began to become more critical of
philanthropy in general I began taking a
little heat for the direction that my
research was taking and both because of
that and also I made a personal decision
not to take any more nor anthropic funds
so this book was actually written
without any funds although much of the
research was done on other projects that
were funded by foundations the people
that are mad at you are they from the
right or the left I seem to be hearing
sounds from both sides in other words
people on the left say to me we always
knew this what so what what's new about
this particular issue people on the
right I would say though are more angry
than people on the left what is a
foundation a foundation there are many
types of foundations but generally it's
an endowed institution that makes grants
primarily out of interest income these
are the so called independent
foundations or family foundations around
the country let's go back to the word
endowed what does that mean endowed
means that a corpus of capital is put
aside is invested makes more money out
of itself an endowment is established
for example major institutions
universities have endowments and so on
it's the same as those types of
endowments except foundations make their
grants out of the interest that is
made off of the endowment how many
minutes how many millionaires did you
interview I interviewed 140
multimillionaires and then I also
interviewed a hundred additional
advisors to the very wealthy can you
make any general statement about a
millionaire or multi millionaire they
have a lot of money no in fact I can't
it was very interesting as the study
proceeded I found that people from with
all different kinds of personalities
with all different types of politics
find themselves with lots of money I
would say there were a few
characteristics I noticed one is most of
these people tend to be private
they don't want much to be known about
their wealth because they're afraid that
they'll be inundated with requests for
funding and so on go to some links to
talk about the methodology including the
fact that most of your multi
millionaires he interviewed gave you an
hour time generally that was about the
average time that I spent with him
sometimes I spent a full day sometimes I
spent only 20 minutes tell the story
about the 20 minute interview all right
this was this was a very wealthy man a
self-made entrepreneur who told me that
he could give me 20 minutes of his time
and he kept very strictly to that he
looked at his watch when I came into his
office we were interrupted by a phone
call which I believe was from his wife
he told me that later he timed to the
phone call so that he could tell me
exactly how much time I had remaining he
was extremely breast but to the point
and I felt although I only had 20
minutes that he told me a good deal did
you tape record the interview I tape
recorded all the interviews where I was
allowed to do so most the vast bulk of
these people wanted confidentiality and
some people felt uncomfortable even with
the promise of confidentiality even
having an interview taped who did not
want confidentiality or asked for it
that you name in your book that you can
talk about well there's one person that
I named in my book
a young woman Tracey Gary I interviewed
her once and she wanted confidentiality
and then I chose to interview her again
I wanted some additional information and
during that interview
which was about two years later she
agreed to let me use her name publicly
and this was because she had made some
personal decisions about being
forthright concerning her philanthropy
so that's an example most of the people
I named in the book however I may or may
not have interviewed them they the
information that's associated with their
name comes strictly from public records
either published records or records that
would be readily available to almost
anyone newspaper accounts magazine
articles so on it's public policy good
to people that have money extremely good
to people that have money in fact my
findings seem to indicate that it
depends on what kind of public policy
you're talking about I'd like to keep
myself within the arena of charity and
philanthropy and nonprofit organizations
but the tax code in general both the
income tax code on the estate tax system
are extremely helpful to wealthy
individuals can you give us an example
sure the more money you give away the
more you can deduct from income tax up
to a certain limit also in terms of
estate planning and and I won't get too
complicated here but essentially you can
give almost all of your fortune to your
heirs tax-free if you set up certain
instruments with good tax attorneys that
allow wherein you give a certain amount
of interest income to certain charities
these can be charities you choose
yourself and once that interest income
has been given away then the bulk of the
fortune can be passed on to heirs
millionaires money that they have left
over do they like to give it on to their
heirs well let me let me clarify that
the people I interviewed tend to be the
most generous millionaires in other
words these are people who give a good
deal of money to philanthropy so if if
anything my study is somewhat biased
toward the most generous
multimillionaires and I estimate that
only about half of the various richest
people in the country give vast sums of
money away so so just to sort of
at the context there if that's helpful
and you'll have to repeat your question
sorry I got away with no no the question
was do many what a millionaire's think
about giving my ears yes that's right
then of the most generous people most
people want to pass money on to their
ears a few people are like Carnegie for
example and they don't believe their
ears should get anything but almost
everyone I talked with has a desire to
pass their fortune on also has a desire
to do some good with the money during
their lifetime and after their death you
saw a bias in your study about where
people like to give their philanthropic
money where was that
well I found that among elite
philanthropists among these
multimillionaires they primarily tend to
fund the kinds of institutions that
they've been personally involved with
their whole lives so these would be the
prep schools that they attended the
private colleges and universities from
which they graduated on the whole these
are Ivy League universities are very
prestigious and institutions what I call
the high arts that is ballet opera the
symphony art museums things of this sort
they tend to fund cultural events they
don't on the whole tend to give very
large grants to programs that serve the
needy the poor the bulk of the
population so my basic argument here is
the government is cutting back but
wealthy people at least do not are not
going to find it in their interests to
begin providing for the kinds of things
that the government has stopped doing it
you think the government ought to make
it easy for a wealthy person to give
money to art yes I do
I'm not at all opposed to the incentives
for giving to art in fact I think the
current controversy revolving around the
National Endowment for the Arts is
something that we need to take a close
look at because a lot of philanthropic
money has supported the Arts I'm not
saying that philanthropy shouldn't be a
matter of choice for the individual I'm
saying that the federal government
should be providing certain for certain
programs so that philanthropy can play a
different role so
philanthropy can be innovative so that
people can make choices about where they
want to put their money and so on so
that experimental programs can be funded
so that advocacy organizations can do
their work can you give us your ideal I
mean maybe you can name a person in your
study that would be your ideal
multimillionaire my just my own personal
ideal personal idea
well that's very difficult because you
know all of these people are individuals
with their good qualities and possibly
their flaws but I'm in the name Tracy
Geary again only because this is an
example of a woman who has given at
least half of her fortune away to
charity who has tried to direct the
money to a certain extent through
women's foundations she helped to
establish the women's foundation in San
Francisco she served on the board oh no
I don't believe she ever served on the
board but she she was key in getting it
started and and then she led a board
that was a more representative board
make decisions about where the money
actually went instead of as an
individual or with her advisors making
all the decisions about where the money
should be dispersed I guess I admire the
group of individuals who often are
called the rich kids they inherited
their wealth their three or four
generations removed from the source of
the fortune there and about my age range
they grew up in the 60s and they feel
uneasy about the kind of noblesse oblige
that their parents and grandparents were
involved in and and they're trying to
give give over some of their privilege
some of their power the power that's
bestowed within philanthropy to more
representative group of people give us
an example of one that you were doing
about one that you don't admire one that
they are the opposite well the opposite
would be someone like Donald Trump who
by the way didn't let me interview
and who who we could characterize as not
being among the philanthropic elite in
other words he's a self-made millionaire
or he it's questionable how self-made he
is this is just reading from published
documents I understand his father owned
a great deal of real estate as well but
he's one of these people who wants to
have and does have the biggest yacht in
the world his own private jet the
biggest penthouse at the top of Trump
Tower the biggest mansions and so on he
represents the other end of the spectrum
most of the people with whom I talked do
not live ostentatious we they live
relatively simply although they're you
know not lacking anything materially it
would be difficult to tell them apart
from the middle class for example from
professionals in terms of where most the
houses that must have been within the
cars that must have been drive they
choose to give conspicuously rather than
to live conspicuously I don't know do
you want is that yeah you just mention
something I'm looking at a footnote here
in the back under your notes during the
course of this research I observe cars
of almost every make parked outside of
rich people's homes why did you why did
you make that note well I think we make
a lot of assumptions about wealthy
people you know that they're all driving
Rolls Royces or they're all driving
Mercedes and in fact I found it quite
interesting that it was difficult to to
tell immediately what the net worth of
these people was I tried to do so
through public records very often these
people don't even think of themselves as
wealthy and they don't live the kind of
lifestyle that you'd see for example
depicted on lifestyles of the rich and
famous or a television program at that
type so cars were just one way to give
the reader a sense of that another very
interesting example that one
millionairess who had inherited her
wealth told me is that she considered
herself a Volvo liberal rather than a
Cadillac liberal and I tried to
understand what it was she was getting
at and and it's humorous in a way
because I actually called some car
dealerships and
found out that bulldozers and Cadillacs
are virtually comfortable in terms of
their price but she had an image of a
Volvo as being a more middle-class kind
of car less showy possibly more
dependable cars are one way in which we
judge people's status in the world what
kinds of cars they drive what kinds of
houses they live in whether or not they
wear designer clothes what's the
difference between old money and new
money well most of the people that I
inherited two-thirds of them came from
old money that is that I integrated
inherited I want to make sure oh I beg
your pardon sir most of this money had
been made at the turn of the century by
the so called robber barons and others
who were associated with them and have
been and the money it has been in the
family for several generations that's
old money it's very difficult to tell
where old money begins and ends new
money of course is money that's made I
try to do it by generations in the book
is an easy shorthand way new money is
first generation money it's money that's
made by the individual themselves I
identified during the course of this
research what I called a culture of
philanthropy in other words these people
find meaning in their lives through
their giving to nonprofit organizations
and through their volunteering with
these types of groups and that culture
is very much a part of the family
tradition of people with so-called old
money so it's old many people who sort
of set set the standards establish the
cultural mores and so on that then the
additional third of the new millionaires
that I interviewed choose to follow
choose to learn choose to live by our
statistics 1% of the American people
have 26 point something percent of the
wealth yes it's it's simply a statistic
about how great the concentration of
wealth is in the United States and
that's from a government study
as a matter of fact so and the
concentration of wealth is increasing in
the United States was the other
statistic that 68 percent of the wealth
in this country is held by 10 percent of
the partners right right so it's kind of
like an inverted pyramid do you have any
chance if you don't have money today of
getting in that 10% of that 1% well of
course you have a chance and I'm not an
expert on that because I simply
interviewed people who had money but you
have much less of a chance what I found
is that fortunes grow once you have them
you need if you have at least a little
bit of capital then you're able to make
that capital grow and grow and grow
especially if you're a member of some of
these old money families that I talked
about that made the decision generation
or so ago to invest the money in common
as occur almost as a corporation to keep
the family money together instead of
breaking it up if is this the line of
reasoning that you wanted me to pursue
here no okay if if the decision is to
pass a fortune on let's say one
individual has three children and a
self-made millionaire has three children
and he excuse the sexist language but on
the whole the individuals making the
money were men he passes it on to his
three children and then they have three
children each that's nine children by
the third generation that money can have
started to disappear and be much smaller
on the other hand if the decision was
made in the first or second generation
to keep the family money together
possibly to invest it out of a family
office that's often what it's called a
family office then then I found with the
those that I interviewed and from the
public records that I investigated that
the fortunes tend to grow the Mellon
family for example is a good
illustration of that and and I portray
them in the chapter on people with old
money statistic there are 25,000 nearly
25,000 private foundations in the United
States what's the difference between a
private foundation I'm probably fine all
right
a private foundation is controlled by a
board of directors that has no
particular
strengths opponent although it's a board
of directors generally most of these
25,000 private foundations are family
controlled the people serving on the
board are family members Friends of
family members or advisors to family
members in comparison or contrast a
public foundation is a foundation
wherein the board is somehow
representative of the community now a
community foundation for example is a
public foundation and very often
Community Foundation's have businessmen
on in the community on them and I would
question how truly representative even
many Community Foundation's are but by
law a public foundation has to have a
different kind of governance structure
which is more democratic than a private
foundation and most of your millionaires
multi millionaires when they create a
foundation create a private foundation
that's right what's the largest in the
country yep the largest private
foundation the Ford Foundation now I
want to caution you that the Ford
Foundation is a foundation we all think
about because it is the largest because
it gives so many grants it's rare though
in comparison to many other foundations
which are like the charitable checkbooks
of the wealthy family the Ford
Foundation hat is a truly independent
foundation it has a board of directors
that no longer has any association
whatsoever with the Ford family another
example of a foundation which will be
among the largest is to be among the
largest is the Packard Foundation
established by David Packard and his
wife Lucille and that is a private
foundation in at which at this time it's
almost totally family controlled that
his family members serve on the board
and it's also a large foundation David
Packard we've seen a lot of it he was a
Deputy Secretary of Defense he headed up
the Packard Commission who is he and why
did he how did he make so much money
well he's one of the co-founders
co-creators of the hewlett-packard
corporation which as most of you know is
a high-technology corporation build
a lot of computers I believe the bulk of
his money was made was made through his
company at some point in his life he and
from the records that I was able to pull
out it seems his wife had a great deal
of influence decided to put much of that
money into a foundation a private
foundation which they established which
serves communities in the Northern
California area where the Packard family
lives where mr. Packard lives presently
you open up chapter six by saying in the
spring of 1988 75 year old David Packard
the co-founder of Hewlett Packard a
leading computer and electronics firm
announced that he would donate two
billion dollars of his fortune to the
David and Lucile Packard Foundation
right and I chose I chose to open the
chapter and self-made millionaires this
way because it was timely he had just
made the announcement there was a lot of
public information about the Packard's
the Packard's are are interesting they
fund a lot of interesting projects but
on the whole I found that they like like
other individuals who I actually
interviewed in the case cases where I
named people I might not necessarily
have interviewed them so it's only
materials that are available to me that
I could go on anyway
he and his family tend to fund the sorts
of projects that interest them the sorts
of projects in which they're very
involved for example his wife before her
death was quite involved in a number of
projects supporting the arts supporting
a Children's Hospital he is a both of
them I believe our alumni of Stanford
University they've contributed huge
amounts of money to Stanford University
an example of the type of university
although not technically an Ivy League
institution Stanford is the type of
university that most of the individuals
I interviewed would give their largest
donations to what do they want from the
money they give to these universities
well it varies I I describe it as a
spectrum some wealthy individuals simply
want to choose where their money goes
they'd rather make the decision rather
than
in taxes and somehow having the
government to make the decision about
where the money goes and they get
certain self-satisfaction out of their
donations they they give to things they
believe in and they think they're doing
good in this way so that's one end of
the spectrum the other end of the
spectrum are individuals who want
control over the organizations that they
fund they're willing to give possibly
let's say ten million dollars to an
institution but they want to have
something to say about how the
institution uses the money and so on
someplace in the middle of that spectrum
are where most people fall most of these
wealthy individuals fall they want the
self-satisfaction they want their name
associated with a wing of the hospital
or in the case of universities the
library or a building or an endowed
professorship but they're not
necessarily going to say the money
should only go to this on the other hand
just coming back to Packard to make the
example more concrete a good deal of
this of these funds have gone to support
programs in the sciences at Stanford
programs in engineering at Stanford now
we can readily understand why this
happened I believe I have my facts right
out that David Packard himself has a
degree in engineering from Stanford and
he he wants to support his alma mater
just as you and I would want to support
our alma mater the difference is I argue
that he gets a large tax break at for
his country he or let's move away from
him in particular but multimillionaires
get large tax breaks both on income tax
and in their estate plans and
inheritance taxes for giving to the
institutions that they choose well let's
just go to the core of the matter when
you see somebody that just given Walter
Annenberg just give 50 million dollars
to the United Negro right colleges wrong
title there are we supposed to own on
and say what a terrific thing he's done
or are we supposed to say well if you
really look at that's a tax break well I
think we should do both mr. Annenberg
made this contribution since the book
was already written
so it's not included in the book I think
we should do and I think it was a good
decision on his part I think it fall
it's some a somewhat exceptional grant
in that it didn't go to his own alma
mater but he obviously had given a great
deal of thinking to what kinds of
institutions he wanted to bolster up and
he chose black colleges and universities
what I think we need to do is scrutinize
the giving of the wealthy much more
closely we need to not make the
assumption that it's always doing good
we need we're all very proud in the
United States of philanthropy of the not
so called nonprofit sector of charity in
general and what I call for in this book
is is a reassessment of what it how does
charity actually function in our society
is it truly charity I think most of us
would think charity was assisting the
needy and yet I found that most wealthy
people don't actually assist the needy
with their charity so I suppose we could
make the distinction between charity and
philanthropy there is there a time in
your past where the light bulb went off
and you say this really makes me mad I'm
going to do something about it I'm gonna
write this book yes it was during the
course of the study late in the study
with about my third year at Yale the
interview that would be 1986 and I was
completing the study of the health of
the foundation field and I was beginning
to write up results and working with
with the research team we worked very
collaboratively and I would write
something that my other team members
fellow researchers would call me on I
would say things like foundations help
to perpetuate the status quo in the
United States and they'd say well you
can't write something like that and I'd
say well why not it's here and the data
and I began to see that even as
researchers they they had profound
reservations about calling to task
something that we consider to be almost
wholly within our society in other words
we think of these kinds of activities as
being
such good activities and especially
given the political climate when people
like President Bush are saying our
problems will be solved by the thousand
points of light
it wasn't very politically popular
anyway this is the time period eighty
six about four years ago that I began I
began really seriously thinking these
things through in a different way kind
of looking at it differently and I began
presenting some papers also just on my
own which presented my own analysis and
interpretation of the data and I I
received hostile receptions to these
papers where did you pretend out if the
papers were presented to a group of
strictly academics there was no problem
at all the academics listened to
tentatively at attentively asked good
questions but if I were to present the
paper to an audience of grantmakers that
is people who either work for
foundations or are wealthy themselves
and give funds away to nonprofit
organizations there are a number of
professional organizations of this sort
or to the kinds of organizations that
represent nonprofit groups in this
country perhaps lobby for nonprofit
groups and so on then the reception
would would be almost cold and and
people people weren't even willing to
listen to me it was as if I was saying
the emperor has no clothes at one
particular conference the keynote
speaker chose to point point me out and
and say yes Teresa there is no Santa
Claus and I gave a lot of thought what
what did he mean there is no Santa Claus
this was declined by the way who was the
former president of the Rockefeller
Foundation and I don't know how
consciously he chose his metaphor but it
seems to me that he was saying that I
was reveal everybody knows there is no
Santa Claus but we shouldn't be
revealing it because Santa Claus is good
because we think of Santa Claus fondly
anyway I'm going on at some length but
then I did have another experience which
which more or less confirmed
for me what I had begun to suspect from
the interviews and from my work with the
interviews and my additional
conversations with the wealthy and that
is that I was employed as the first
executive director of the Women's
Foundation of Colorado this is one of
several new foundations that are
springing up around the country created
by women funded by women to serve
women's causes and in the course of that
employment which turned out to be rather
brief I became a participant observer
with at least with the wealthy women who
had helped to establish the foundation
and began to see that and and I don't
mean to single them out because in a way
I mean I am singling them out but
they're not that different from any
other type of enterprise of this sort
which is that they were just as
interested in creating the foundation to
establish their own power base to
increase their own influence as they
were to provide for other women to
improve the status of women in the state
of Colorado did you do all the work on
this by yourself on this particular book
I did I didn't do all the interviews
myself there was a team of interviewers
however I listened to every tape again
and read every transcript again and we
analyzed all of the interviews since the
Yale study ended so that the book is a
work of a single person dedication for
Michael Bernstein who is he he's my
partner the father of my daughter an
economic historian at the University of
California at San Diego and he was a
great support to me throughout the whole
project both literally and figuratively
you also mentioned I said I can find it
I had it underlined here in the
beginning a couple of other Odin dolls
right my parents Eric and a Mary those
are my parents my father painstakingly
edited the entire manuscript and
commented on it for me
he's a journalist and he teaches at San
Diego's
University and my mother who works for
the Presbyterian Conference of San Diego
also read the manuscript and commented
on it so a lot of friends and family
supported me in this project when did
you finish it well the book literally
came out less than a month ago so I
guess that's what you call actually
finishing it
it was impressed almost a year however
so I finished it just about a year ago a
couple of things I underlined I have
tried to be honest about my biases right
they're hard well I think very often
social scientists like to present
themselves as if their research is value
free as if their methodology somehow
they've never raised any of their own
biases because they've used a
statistical methodology or whatever and
I just wanted to make the point
especially since these were personal
interviews since they're open to a great
deal of interpretation that right at the
beginning I wanted to let the reader
know what what my overall arguments were
and and what my biases might be
everyone has biases I'm not sure that
everyone admits to them that's all
another note here I am NOT a member of
the class I described right I'm not
wealthy I grew up you know sort of
solidly middle class and I've never
wanted for anything in my life but
actually until these interviews are not
certain that I really was ever
personally acquainted with any
multimillionaires before quote your your
comments it is the burden of my argument
that the rich do not find it in their
interest to fund or provide social
programs on a sufficient scale right
right I am NOT trying to say that the
wealthy individuals should be putting
all their money into programs that serve
the needy I'm rather saying that we have
a structural situation in which there
are in which the federal government is
not providing for providing a what you
could call a basic federal safety net
we can see it all around us with more
homeless people on the streets and so on
I'm not trying to show how that safety
net can be provided I'm simply trying to
show how the particular role that this
group of wealthy individuals play in
supporting a structural situation that
may in many senses exacerbate inequality
instead of helping to redistribute
wealth go back to that chapter
first-generation men and their families
another person that you mentioned in
here is George clever huh real name no
that's a pseudonym now and actually
George Klepper is is I believe five
individuals and what I had to do in
order to protect the confidentiality of
the people we interviewed was to take
people take individuals who were all of
the same gender who were all of the same
generation from wealth in this case mr.
Klepper was a first-generation
millionaire who who generally were just
about the same age so you he he was an
older man I I think he was in fact over
60 years of age so all five of these
individuals had those traits in addition
to having those demographic or personal
traits they all said very similar things
in their interviews so that I collapsed
them together formed a composite and and
then was able to present material that
didn't identify any one of the five of
them through this one individual this is
a question of no substance where did you
invent the name George Klepper I don't
know I think I just made it up I do know
other names how where they came from you
know even sort of people I once had
known and I picked up on that name or or
people friends had known I was asking
friends what names I should use I did
try to avoid any actual names
in other words if I knew that there was
a wealthy person who had the name
Klepper then I wouldn't have used the
name Klepper in fact I think I had
invented a name Paul Mitchell it was
just a pseudonym for one of the
self-made millionaire
that I feature and and then I realized
that there was this line of products
that are called Paul Mitchell products
so I had to change that name I want to
read you what you said under the George
Klepper part of this chapter you quote
him as saying or this composite we have
about 80 guys working on our income
taxes right 80 guys working on our
income taxes the income taxes of the
family I think he's talking about the
Trust's that he established this
individual and the other individuals
that make up the composite had decided
to establish to put all their money into
trusts and in fact the corporation I
believe was in the form of a trust and
what he was saying was that it took 80
individuals to actually it was so
complicated the trust arrangements that
that it took this many government
employees to actually check out their
taxes how much was he worth I don't
recall although all of the individuals
that I who were included in the hundred
and forty the count of a hundred and
forty by the way I did interview other
people who didn't quite make the hundred
and forty but who supplemented my
general characterization they had at
least five million dollars of net worth
his particular corporation I may have
mentioned it there was it's quite a
large corporation now and I believe that
if it isn't him there's some others who
would qualify to be on the Forbes list
of the 400 400 okay I wasn't sure
whether that individual was so he so
he's incredibly wealthy okay let me read
a little more yeah we have five members
of the United States government who do
nothing but check us right five members
of the United States that's a direct
quote so I'm I on the whole I decided to
treat the statements made to me as truth
let me just read a little more so I can
complete this to check us through the
whole year they sit and work on us we
had to her in another place for them
right for the government right right the
deal when you hear that does that make
you feel good that they're five
will that work for the government no it
doesn't make me feel one way or another
this isn't a question of how I feel the
point I was trying to make though in
that particular vignette is that this
individual and the other individuals who
he represents are very against taxation
and this is the case with almost all of
the millionaire's that I interviewed
it's one of the reasons that he set up
the trust instruments so that he could
avoid taxation and then what happened in
his is trying to avoid taxation is that
he made more work for it for these
officials as well Brian Dolan owns a
large construction and land development
firm in Chicago right endowing
nonprofits not the next generation you
caught him here is saying the kids are
well taken care of and too much money
will kill you just like liquor right
what's Brian Dolan story well your posit
again but yeah composite again he's an
individual who said that he didn't want
to pass the bulk of his fortune on to
his children that he would rather give
the bulk of his fortune to nonprofit
organizations I think he betrays himself
however in that particular quotation by
saying the kids are well taken care of
and and then later he tells me that he
has actually already passed some money
on to his kids he's used some charitable
trust instruments but but he is an
individual who is very committed to
giving to nonprofit organizations in his
case he is a graduate of Harvard
University as I recall or institution
followed and and he's given a good deal
of money to Harvard University and
that's quite typical of the individuals
that I interviewed by the way let me
stop there at the university thing and I
may be wrong about this but I think I
read recently because they did an
article here in town about all the
universities and their endowments and
when the president of American
University had to quit in a controversy
that they had is something like an
endowment of
twenty million dollars American
University okay and I just read that
Harvard University has an endowment of
five billion dollars that's right
Harvard has the largest endowment of any
educational institution how does one
university get five billion in another
well-known University of 20 million
well Harvard University is has much more
elite reputation than American
University Harvard University has
graduated many more individuals in the
fillin that that I would put in the
philanthropic a lead although they're
both private universities Harvard
University is in a sense the
personification of of the of the kinds
of things I'm talking about here this is
the kind of institution that wealthy
people are going to tend to fund now a
self-made millionaire who might have
graduated who might have been more
likely to have graduated from American
University let's say could very well
decide to give quite a large sum of
money into American University's
endowment but simply by virtue of the
fact that people with old money have
attended these institutions very often
generation after generation and
generation after generation have
supported these institutions and have
given funds into their endowments means
that the endowments of the Harvard's the
Yale's the Princeton the Stanford's are
going to be much larger than the
endowments of other kinds of talking
about the book charity begins at home
and here's another chapter I want to ask
you this is I think it's chapter 7 why a
chapter titled elite Jewish giving well
as I said we did interviews throughout
the United States mostly in metropolitan
areas and every major metropolitan area
that we visited when we were asked who
are the leading philanthropists in this
city we were given at least several
names of Jewish philanthropists part of
the way in which I was able to arrange
these interviews was that one individual
who would allow me to establish rapport
with them and interview
than would introduce me to another
individual and so on so we discovered
and this had not been something that I
anticipated that Jews are quite active
in philanthropy in in much greater
numbers and proportion than their
percentage in the population I believe
that there are many fewer than 10% of
the total population is Jewish and yet I
found that we had to actually
interviewed 40 out of 140 Jewish
philanthropist there's also a separate
chapter on Jewish giving as there is on
people with old money people with new
money and women philanthropists Jewish
philanthropy is the fourth category that
I established because Jews have a
different you might call it style of
giving as well and I felt there were
enough differences between this group
and the other groups to highlight them
one of them is that the fundraising
practices of many Jews are different
from that of non-jews such as the
practice of called
card calling I don't know if you're
familiar with that that would be at a
social function generally honoring
someone who is quite a generous giver
that giver would announce what his gift
is going to be this particular year to
the institution that he's that he's
choosing to make a donation to generally
the gift is going to be larger than the
gift he made last year he's going to
publicly announce that gift and he's
essentially going to call off cards in
which everyone else in the room their
contribution last year is going to be
mentioned and they're going to be
embarrassed into raising their
contribution and basically the same
proportion that his contribution a very
successful fundraising technique that
would never go over in the the wasp
community as a fundraising strategy in
fact among the old moneyed people
talking about money is taboo you people
will talk about their sex lives more
readily than they'll talk about money so
that's one thing fundraising techniques
also I felt that Jews getting back on to
the subject at hand walk a very fine
line these are wealthy Jews
between maintaining their Jewish
identity and also being accepted into
high society into the culture of
philanthropy that I described throughout
their book and they want both they want
to to think that continue to think of
themselves as Jews and they also want to
be accepted so one of the strategies
that either consciously or not so
consciously both Jews and self-made
millionaires have developed is is to
give into the high arts to give to the
same kinds of institutions that other
members of the culture of philanthropy
does this this helps them to become
members of that culture in the case of
Jews they also give in general about
half of their charity too specifically
Jewish causes either
Jewish social services within the United
States or projects in Israel or or to
their synagogue visits all right you say
you have this large or you have this
small Jewish group give lots of money
and you've talked about Worcester is
there any other segment of our society
that has a unique habit that they and
how they deal with money and becoming
multi millionaires well I thought I I
also have a separate chapter on women
and I think that women are are very
important in fact central to the culture
of philanthropy because in many respects
they bring their families into the
culture now women are in in a somewhat
curious position in that they don't have
even wealthy women do not have as much
status as the men of their class but
they certainly have more power and
influence than both men and women in
other classes and and so they have power
and one of the ways in which they
exercise it is through their
philanthropy on the whole women are much
more involved on a day to day basis with
volunteering with being involved in
nonprofit organizations with putting on
charity balls
serving on nonprofit boards at the
community level than our men
now elite men would tend to either serve
on or head up the boards of national
organizations whereas elite women would
head up the boards of local
organizations at any rate I found that
women play a key role in nonprofits and
also in socializing their children too
to accept this kind of culture to become
members of the culture to to live by the
values of the culture and also it's the
case this is the case with women who
inherit wealth and it's up or marry into
wealth and it's also the case with women
who may be married to self-made
millionaires they may actually bring
their families into the culture of
philanthropy through their involvement
in nonprofit endeavors while their
husbands are still helping their
fortunes to grow making money and then
only later in life does the husband to
normally become as involved we talked
some early about some of the people you
would remember the most that you
interviewed other than the 20-minute
interview who were somewhat I don't
probably have names of most of these
were some of the other types of
instances that you had when you went to
interview that you'll always remember a
couple of things one there was quite an
elderly woman who spent a whole day with
me and wanted me in fact there were a
number of elderly women and this relates
to the earlier topic we were discussing
who who were basically giving me an oral
history of their life and and we spent
all day talking about what they've done
and their involvement and so on there
was also an elderly man who had me it
for some reason the interviews were much
more memorable if the individuals had me
to their homes to conduct the interview
then if they had me to their offices now
on the whole it was either very young
people are very old people who had me to
their homes or and also it was it tended
to be more women than men but he had me
to his home and
he described the situation when he was
very young in which she'd had to have
bodyguards and so on because the family
had been so scared of the possibility of
kidnapping because the family was
wealthy and so on so those were
memorable interviews as well
you're finding a strange situation where
he showed up but the multimillionaires
house they had 35 cats or something like
that no I didn't find any situations
like that there is a situation that I
detail in the first chapter which is
somewhat exceptional in that it was one
of the few mansions that I actually
visited and I came and it was also the
first interview that I conducted I came
to the front door and I was greeted by
the woman herself who had invited me to
her home and she told me that she was
going to show me through the formal part
of the home which was the downstairs of
the mansion and there was almost no
furniture as if this area was meant for
parties was meant for crowds of people
although there were some very exotic
flower arrangements placed on exquisite
pieces of furniture in different places
she took me into a room what she said
was the large dining room and this was a
massive dining room with a huge dining
table and then she said the big kitchen
is over in this direction although she
didn't take me into it and she took me
into another room what she called the
music room and there was a grand piano
at the end of the room and then plenty
of space for an audience
- perhaps listen to her recital and it
became clear from her description that
this was the part of the house that was
used for public and charitable event and
then she took me upstairs for the actual
interview and it was almost as if the
upstairs of the house was like any other
kind of middle-class home that you might
enter into the furniture was you know
quite tasteful but modest and this is
where she had me interview her and she
didn't show me around here this was the
private part of the house this was her
home this was where she and her family
lived but it seemed to me that for some
psychological reason she and her family
chose every day to remind
selves of their well by walking through
this very public area so that that was a
little different because most people
just live in I mean you know possibly
they live in five bedroom houses but
other than that they aren't huge
mansions let me think of some other
instances that that seemed interesting I
think some of the the people that are
often called rich kids we're interesting
these are the young people who grew up
in the 60s and inherited their wealth
and their extremely modestly some of
them even in in poor parts of town and I
might have interviewed them there but
you notice on the inside of their
apartments even they display art many of
these people have both in their business
setting and in their home setting have
have much more art than then you would
typically find in a middle-class home
and the few remaining moments where do
you live now I live in San Diego
California
what next well I'm not sure I have a
general idea about the nonprofit sector
and the way in which you could even
consider it an exploitative sector in
that people tend to be paid less in the
sector many more women work in this
sector both for less pay and as
volunteers them do men a different way
of looking at the whole endeavor of
charity not just wealthy people and
their philanthropy and this book has it
caused enough of a controversy in your
life that it's hard for you to get
another job well I am currently
unemployed so and and I do think that
working on this book has had a bearing
on that I think that if I'd chosen a
very standard career path and less
controversial topic that that I might
have a job at the moment I can't blame
it all on the book though I think that
I've made untraditional types of
decisions in my life as well and I
always seem to make those hard choices
probably will continue to when it comes
to the controversy what what is it that
most people do why do they react so
strongly about something like this and
it does it say something about the
country I think because it is our giving
and volunteering within the United
States which which is always touted as
making us different from other countries
you know and Alex de Tocqueville is
almost without exception and quoted as
saying you know these people are
constantly forming voluntary
associations and so on it's something we
really believe it's a kind of an
ideology about our life and our our way
of providing services that in a sense
I'm taking two tasks now I'm not the
only one who is is taking a very serious
scholarly look at these issues others
others have as well but but I think it's
it's beginning to question the
assumption about charity and
particularly the charity of elites that
it's all doing good this is the name of
the book charity begins at home
Teresa Oden doll is our guest and thank
you for joining us thank you very much